e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était une fois une moment dieu avec
son petit dieu du moment est ce que tu
me donne la permission de faire un monde
tu as fini tes devoirs bon alors c'est
bon tu peux le petit dieu prix d'une
ardoise des craies de couleur et se mit
à faire le monde que le soleil soit le
monsieur est la lune
nadal est il juste une petite fille
qu'on appela la petite aurore ensuite le
petit dieu créa les plantes qui poussent
sur la terre et les algues puis il créa
les bêtes qui marche celle qui rampent
celle qui nagent et celle qui vole
[Musique]
ensuite il créa l'homme qui est le plus
intelligent des animaux de la terre
et quand il lui fait tout cela le ter
était remplie on y allait tous vides qui
veut habiter le ciel tout le monde
entend dit à l'exception du petit cochon
qui était occupé à manger des glandes
chaîne car le petit cochon et si
gourmand quand il mange il n'entend rien
et tous ceux qui voulaient habitait le
ciel vaart à l'appel du petit dieu il
avait le bélier le taureau et le lion il
y avait le scorpion et le crabe qu'on
appelle le cancer ils y avaient leurs
chèvres qu'on appelle cas tricorne il y
avait des poissons il y avait les 200
tort et il y avait les deux ours est une
jeune fille qu'on appelle la vierge
alors le petit dieu les prix les uns
après les autres et les clous à sur la
voûte céleste
à l'aide de ces gros clous d'argent
qu'on appelle les étoiles à c'est très
joli tout ça mais moi quand je me levais
je vais l'aiguillé mais c'est vrai j'y
avais pas pensé
départ dans ce cas c'est ça chaque matin
la petite aurore se lèvera dans une
terre et des clous pas les habitants du
ciel et chaque soir quand il sera couché
elle permettra en place ainsi fut fait
c'est pourquoi chaque matin les étoiles
disparaissent pour ne revenir qu'à la
nuit tombée
et ben moi alors pourquoi ce que
j'habite pas le ciel moi aussi pourquoi
tu me l'a pas demandé qu'est ce que tu
faisais quand j'ai appelé des
volontaires crois que je mange ed
blanchett a tenté pour toi que tu as eu
monsieur le petit dieu trouvez moi une
petite place du temps aux autres de se
ré il ya plus de place tu le vois bien
je veux aller au ciel je vais aller au
ciel ce bien qu'on ne m'aime pas tout le
monde me veut je veux me venger ma
pauvre petit taureau séduit oracle s'est
levé avant le jour pour arracher des
clous moi ça me révolte c'est plutôt
amusant ce travail celle ci tu voulais
je montre avec toi je t'aiderai ton
travail
la fois ci il n'y a que ça pour te faire
plaisir à ces merveilleux je vais deux
fois plus vite que d'habitude
merci petit cochon tout riante orient
petits cochons qu'est ce que tu sais de
l'aube jusqu'à midi elle parcouru l'asie
mais nul n'y avait vu le petit cochon de
médias quatre heures elle parcouru
l'afrique et après 4 heures elle
parcouru l'europe
cependant le petit cochon se sachant
poursuivis s'était réfugié en france à
paris au 69 de la rue broca ce fait une
épicerie buvette qu'un partenaire à papa
saïd ces deux dernières filles malika et
rachid a gardé la boutique sauvez moi je
vous en prie la petite aurore me court
après elle veut me tuer pour me manger
après 6,6 en caisses de l'état alors si
on me demande vous m'avez pas vu un c
compris la petite aurore vous rencontrer
sans doute une histoire à dormir debout
au sujet d'une
toile que j'aurais mangé ce complètement
absurde
pourquoi readily comme valeur sure it et
tu la verras qu'il nous parlait on a dit
non
bonjour mademoiselle est ce que par
hasard vous n'auriez pas vu un petit
cochon rose exactement
nous n'avons pas vu si vous ne l'avez
pas vu comment savez vous qu'il est
lumineux c'est parce qu'il a osé vous
êtes bien sûr de ne pas avoir vu ses
petits cochons la journée finissait
c'était l'heure où la petite aurore
devait remettre en place les habitants
du ciel de toit tu as pris mon étoile
prône la paix de l'ua pour demander toi
le bonheur mais bien qu'est ce qui se
passe bien ce n'est pas malin à présent
il va falloir me dire à ton père à ces
malades
le petit cochon est sûrement chez papa
saïd 8 que l'on me donne mon grand
manteau noir mon chapeau noir mon
écharpe noire mon masque noir et mes
lunettes mois et givet ns et pour
monsieur ce sera rien je voudrais vous
parler je suis le soleil jeudi à
chercher le petit cochon qui a mangé
l'étoile polaire
qu'est ce que vous me racontez ya pas de
petit cochon ici et moi je suis sûr
qu'il y ait ce sont vos enfants qui
l'ont fait entrer vous avez eu un petit
cochon oui un petit cochon panne
hippopotames bien sûr vous êtes sourbes
un petit cochon tout vert voilà la prem
qu'est ce que ça veut dire cacher un
petit cochon chez moi il est ici un chez
moi
lâchez moi je veux rester ici tu verras
tu voudras mais moi je veux l'étoile
belle étoile
je jamais fait de toi ne parle pas tant
un menteur et crache là
et plus le temps n'attend employons les
grands moyens
monsieur saïd avez vous un couteau pour
ta punition
puisque tu aimes tant les choses qui
brillent tu sera changé en tirelire tu
garderas cette fente dans ton dos
monsieur saïd ighli sera les pourboires
est une sera délivrée que quand tu seras
pelade si papa ça ils n'oublient jamais
pressée pour boire dans la fin mai comme
les enfants viennent y puiser je ne dis
pas tous les jours de plusieurs fois par
jour il est à craindre que le petit
cochon ne soit jamais rappelé
[Musique]